what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video that i
came up on my youtube feed um it's
called being ugly and having no friends
at 46
my experience before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um so the reason i
picked this video is because watching
the manosphere has actually given me
insight into some of the struggles that
guys go through that i never really
thought about
um so i don't know i just thought this
would be an interesting video to watch
now probably the most common thing would
be when i'm referring to
i don't think he's like super ugly to be
honest
uh looks or bodily appearance and
whatnot
being ugly is more than just about licks
it can be
about personality how you
behave around uh behavior around other
people yeah if anything he comes off
awkward
um which i would say for a guy is a
bigger detriment
than being ugly because if you're ugly
and funny or you got a good personality
um in general i think you can still get
girls
but if you're awkward it's much harder
your sense of humor and so
obviously it would be logical to reason
that the reason why i have
no friends people who i can call up on
have a conversation with when uh find
someone to win
willingly hang out with me is
probably safe to say because there is
something ugly
about who i am and like i said it's more
than just my looks
and growing up as a child
i was a teased a lot more often than
your typical uh
uh student was i mean i was probably
bullied more frequently than what most
people would experience
bullying uh even despite the fact that i
grew up in a very affluent environment
my parents were really well off and
whatnot it was
i was teased quite a bit more often than
even
other peop other kids who would be
teased on a more frequent basis
and so that kind of uh
led to some challenges but it
interesting
interestingly enough i would still have
friends and i would still have people to
hang out with and i even had
a close friend uh pretty much all the
way up until i was
about eight seven eighteen years of age
we met like in first grade and we became
like really close friends all the way up
until age 18. i
hung out with a couple other people so
pretty much
i generally had friends all the way up
until around my mid-30s
and that is when things kind of really
fell by the wayside and so
pretty much since my mid-thirties i've
essentially had i've essentially had no
friends
and like i said that's kind of a term
that i guess i could kind of use
loosely because i mean you've got like
online friends you've got
you know acquaintances but i'm i'm so
sad for him
referring to like friends and which you
can actually like
hang out with like physically
be able to like you know chat be able to
like hang out
do whatever it may be and i can
attribute that to
is there is something ugly about myself
and even like when i post on facebook
and i try to be funny and i think i'm
being humorous and i find myself
laughing at a particular video i make i
find that
especially on facebook or instagram it's
like people are just
they're not they're not really seeing
any humor and it's like i would think
that if
they were finding it humor they would at
least respond saying that was funny or
that was awesome or whatnot but
i feel like there's there are strategic
ways to be humorous
that are going to help attract people
towards it and then there are ways that
are good
that you can try to be humorous but
they're going to make you sound like a
turd
and i have the feeling that my sense of
humor the way i try to come off as funny
is making me sound like a turd and so
hence you know kind of
it's it's an ugly way of being uh
humorous
my personality my personality is
probably it's
it's not charismatic i'll say that um
more than likely that's due to my
depression and anxiety
as to why my personality is not even
close to being
charismatic at all so
it's you know one thing that programming
has taught me
and this field i'm going into has really
taught me is if something is not working
then there is obviously a malfunction as
i would say
someone who is positively
in a good sense humorous they know how
to socially interact with other people
they know how to say the right things
they're attractive i mean let's face it
even physical attractiveness
is really important it's going to help
them be able to
make friends and whatnot this is making
me so sad
and it's crazy because even as he's
talking and i'd consider myself as
someone to have
like a lot of friends good family etc i
still relate to some of the stuff he's
saying
and i bet that's why this has so many
views but
if you don't have any of those things
going for you then
obviously you're going to have a
difficulty making new friends
establishing relationships and whatnot
and so pretty much
it's like because i mean let's it's it's
not like i'm just like sitting in my
apartment all day
never venturing out and whatnot i mean
i'm
you know i'm taking you know i'm
pursuing uh a master's degree in data
science i'm doing it part time right now
i get out there and ski obviously i come
across a lot of people when i'm skiing
on the mountain even during this
time we're having to like socially
distance and whatnot
i'm doing cycling uh and then
of course before the pandemic i was
doing obstacle course racing tough
mudder
spartans even going to like post
uh after parties and whatnot so it was
not like i wasn't
not putting myself out there but there
is something
that is that i feel is really ugly about
myself that is
repelling people from me that that is
that is
inhibiting me from being able to
establish those relationships
and one thing and i'm going to make a
separate video about this that's really
interesting about
data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence
is let's just let's just use an example
let's i'm just going to kind of uh
make create an example here as to why
this field is really exciting and how i
feel
it could ultimately reduce if not
potentially end
loneliness and help all of us who feel
ugly inside
to one day feel attractive not
physically but
attractive overall because that's when
it comes down to making friends when it
comes down to dating
finding intimacy it all comes down to
having that attractive personality
you know and combination of looks
personality
humor the way you speak and so let's say
that you decide to have you decide to
have
uh 100 people have a 45-minute
conversation with an
interviewer the interviewer will ask the
exact same questions to every person
and these 100 people have a you know
they have a good
uh close circle of friends they're in a
relationship
and you will you do some analysis on
their voice
uh patterns like you have some
interfaces like measuring their speech
rate
their amp their voice amplitude what
their range of amplitude is uh
paused between words uh how many what's
their frequency of saying certain types
of words
they uh icon i can already tell that i'm
interested in this intact and you'll
probably notice
patterns and there's and there's
in these people's speeches or yeah and
these people's uh
speech now take another sample of a
hundred people
and they speak with the the same
interviewer same exact environment
but yet these 100 people have no friends
they've never had it you know they've
pretty much never had a relationship and
you would probably notice
differences in speech patterns amp you
know amplitude uh
voice inflection patterns uh eye contact
body you know body posture what i'm
getting at
is i feel like this artificial
intelligence
the use of machine learning you know you
know with advanced machine learning
models and whatnot
is the way that's gonna it's gonna lead
to the way to ultimately
reduce what i kind of refer to as
uh and i shouldn't say i it's i've read
the uh read the term and articles
it's called death despair uh
despair death i can't now i'm losing my
train of thought
death due to this disparities meaning
like oftentimes
sometimes i can't really rule out an
overdose death as a suicide because it
could be accidental
or it could be suicidal but they're
calling these like deaths of disparities
meaning
people who are in despair oftentimes may
resort to using
uh drugs like hard drugs like heroin
cocaine
or they may you know start you know
binge drinking
regardless of whatever drugs they start
becoming addicted to
sometimes to get that feel good feeling
you're going to resort to using drugs
and so often you know if you're you get
to the point where you become
so accustomed to using this drug that
you risk having an overdose
and whether or not it's accidental or
maybe it's intentional that's where kind
of the line astronauts they don't really
know
whether or not it's accidental or
suicide in some of these cases so
what i'm getting at is i feel like it's
going to become
a combination of therapeutic
therapeutical methods
in combination with using artificial
intelligence
to really dive deep into this
art of social interaction because it it
there is a science
behind i would wonder if it's because we
have less and less contact with people
and things are becoming more and more
virtual that people's communication
skills are getting less and less
and this art of successful social
interaction
there is an art to developing a more
attractive persona within ourselves
that's what i'm getting at uh
someone who is ugly you know an ugly
person
and i'm you know i'm just i'm not
talking about like this look like once
again i'm not talking about my
my looks in general i'm talking about my
purse my persona and journal
because i have an ugly persona
it is logical it is a logical assumption
to assume that that's probably why i
have no friends that's probably why i'm
a loner that's probably why i have
difficulty finding a good job
well i can't even get an interview i
have no network is because my persona
is ugly and that leads to
a lot of loneliness that leads to
depression anxiety
it makes it leads to questioning uh my
purpose of my existence
and i'm so sad
and i know this kind of i know this is
uh
people will be like you gotta quit you
know you gotta quit uh
you know being you know uh degrading
yourself but i'm just being honest i'm
i'm perfectly being honest that i
realize that there is something ugly
about myself that is repelling people
i mean so it's kind of difficult for me
to really come up with
i just want to give them a heart videos
where i try to be funnier or whatnot
because
maybe i'm laughing at them but to other
people i may be sounding like a complete
turd you know a complete you know just a
complete idiot
and so that's kind of why i haven't
really i've been really hesitant on
uploading any kind of videos where i
kind of you know i start laughing or
whatnot because really i don't know if
i'm really
doing more harm to myself so i've kind
of come to the point where
now that i'm really getting into this
field of data science and realizing
there's a science to this
art of social interaction an art to
having
an attractive personality the art to
being attractive
overall and so i find it's best that
i kind of have to adopt a neutral stance
meaning like when i'm going out skiing
maybe i need to stop wearing these
bright colors when i'm skiing it
because i worry it's like super bright
orange uh
cycling vests and whatnot and that's
okay if i'm cycling because you want to
be seen you don't want to have some car
pull out
and cold [ __ ] a car at some you know
miles per hour and that could
be really bad but when i'm skiing and
out in the mountain do i really need to
be
flashing myself in bright colors no
maybe get like a gray or black you know
jacket pants are okay but just kind of
make myself more discreet
not like you know make it so i'm not
like trying to grab attention
and when i'm out in the mountain and i'm
doing cycling i want to keep a straight
face don't like
you know start exaggerating or like so
trying to just be like i just need to be
i just need to kind of develop
a foundation i need to strip myself of
whatever's making me ugly
completely strip of it and they
the old adage is like just be yourself
and you will
attract people who like you for who you
are they all like you
for being you but
i i find i find some flaws with that
because unfortunately we do live in a
society i feel like we live in a society
where
you cannot truly be yourself you've got
to be within a range of what is
acceptable
to be able to fit i feel like there's
levels of yourself like for example
you know i try to be who i am regardless
of who i'm around but there are certain
things that i would say around one group
of friends that i wouldn't
say around another just because i know
that group of friends beliefs or the way
they feel about certain things like the
nanosphere content
i i have friends i could talk about this
stuff with i friends that i wouldn't
fit in to be able to be accepted to be
able to be loved
and if you're outside of that range it's
going to become more difficult and you
risk
you know spending more time alone and
whatnot so
pretty much what i've got to really
focus on and next time i go skiing i'm
going to really be focusing on this and
tomorrow i think i'm going to go out
there and buy myself a gray something
that's aerodynamic but like black or
grey it's something that's a lot more
discreet
and when i'm skiing i'm just going to
focus on keeping a straight face i hope
like a social coach reached out to him
because i think this got a lot of views
that would be a cute story of course you
know it doesn't really matter too much
because i'm wearing a mask and whatnot
but
just kind of keep a straight face if i'm
going to do a spread eagle
just kind of do it you know just kind of
do it really discreetly don't
exaggerate just kind of like be serious
and have fun like if i'm going to say
i'm having fun just be like
that was a pretty cool run i'm going to
do that again but don't be like
you know i you know just i have a
feeling that's really irritating to a
lot of people when i start like yelling
and hooting and hollering
so i just got to be like or i'm skiing
or running
the albental backcountry and it's
becoming challenging just be like oh
yeah this doesn't want this run doesn't
seem to want to end
okay keep going keep going all right all
right i'm obviously slowing down
just kind of be neutral so there is a
lot of work i got to do on myself
because if something it's like it's kind
of like an
if else statement if something isn't
working don't continue it
if something works continue with that so
obviously what i've been doing
is not working so i need to kind of
switch switch the routine a little bit
make myself more
neutral strip myself of any annoyances
and just kind of start from the from the
beginning maybe
maybe i can be like an observer kind of
watch how other people interact
what what are the types of things they
say what you know
what what kinds of things are likely to
make people laugh what's
you know what what can i do and just
kind of be an observer and it's kind of
like build from the beginning and then
maybe
once i get you know more comfortable
then i can be like
you know if i meet you know once this
pandemic ends and people i'm i sit with
someone that cheerless
maybe i can be like how's your day going
you've been up here in the mountain long
and it's kind of start really super
basic
and from there that's you know that's
where it starts getting a lot more
complicated and like how to be
being able to how to you know maintain a
conversation
and whatnot but i just wanted to kind of
get this video out there and just kind
of share my thoughts and
just the struggles of really feeling
like that uh
i'm being you know that i'm that that
you know just being ugly
leads to a lot of loneliness just a lot
of emptiness
kind of a lack of purpose in life kind
of even hopeless and you know am i going
to really ever amount to anything
so my battery's about to run out so i'm
just going to kind of cut it
wow
ah this guy um 220
234 000 views this was in march
um let's see he said an update i've
gotten off the couch dips
ditched that striped striped shirt and
joined a few
different hiking groups i feel that i
have made significant progress compared
to where i was this past march and
compared to most of my 40s for that
matter thank you to all the viewers and
all your helpful
suggestions and i even welcome
constructive constructive
criticism although i've made a lot of
progress i have a long way to go
i do i still do battle with those
feelings of being ugly inside i still
take it one day at a time
the time has come when people should
feel comfortable being vulnerable and
should not have to keep things inside i
will continue to keep you guys updated
um
wow this is i'm not going to read the
whole thing but this is like
wow i'm like i'm like so sad
it's weird how much i take for granted
like
social skills even you know a lot of my
life
i felt really i don't want to say i'm
outcasted but a little bit because
i don't know i've always been like the
quirky girl that talks a lot
and you know rambles about crazy like
psychology ideas and like
crazy you know
economically like whatever thing i'm
interested in learning about
at the time and it was always really
hard for me to find like people that i
felt like
were goofy like me but also would think
in like a
critical thinking way like i don't know
if that makes sense but
it's just oh my gosh enough to sneeze um
it's just crazy how much you know you
take for granted just like the
simple social skills that come from like
growing
being in a big family and like involved
and stuff
and then it makes me wonder like why is
this social stuff so hard for him
so i don't know clearly a lot of people
related to that but
let me know in the comments what your
thoughts are let me know if there's been
a time where you guys have felt like you
didn't fit in
or anything do not forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys
next time